ضربت القطط عديمة الأسنان أبرامز ، كما يقول
مذيع وسائل الإعلام الروسية الحكومية يشير إلى
رسم ضخم يزعم وجود عيوب في
دبابات الناتو ، حيث تقلل دعايته الهادفة من
المخاطر التي يبدو أن القوات الروسية في
أوكرانيا تعمل على
إرسال الدبابات سيكون أمرًا سيئًا
للأمريكيين والألمان  إنها تقول
إننا سنفوز بغض النظر عن أن سيرجي
يخبرنا أن الأمر مجرد توسيع نطاق
الصراع إذا انسحبنا من الغرب
سيضع مزيدًا من الضغط علينا ولكن لا
يشتري الجميع الضجيج التلفزيوني الحكومي الذي قتل فيه بوتين
وسائل الإعلام المستقلة ولكن ليس
استقلال العقل
هذا الشاب.  طالبة سينما تخبر فريقنا أن
صديقًا قد تم تجنيده ونشره ولكنه
اختفى الآن أنا من أجل السلام وتقول
إنه من المحزن جدًا أن يموت الناس أنا على
وشك البكاء هنا
لا أعرف ما إذا كان هذا صحيحًا أم لا أو
ما الذي يحدث  في هذه الحرب تخبرنا هذه السيدة
ولكني أعرف أشخاصًا
قُتلوا بعضهم أصدقاء.
تهديد
نفوذها ، يحتاج بوتين إلى حشد المزيد من
المجندين
لمطحنة اللحوم التي لا تحظى بشعبية متزايدة ، وهي خنادق الخطوط الأمامية في أوكرانيا
في المزيد من الدعاية في وقت الذروة
لبوتين.
سأل مساعد الجمهور بجنون فلاديمير سولوفيوف
الجمهور بعد أن كل هذا ليس برلين
هدفًا قانونيًا
مثل الخياطة في وسائل الإعلام الروسية
بوتين قادر على إرسال أي
رسالة تقريبًا يريد أن تقدم الدمى التليفزيونية الخاصة به
بسرعة والخوف بنفس القدر ولكن حتى هذا
لا تسير الأمور على ما يرام مع بعض
الأعمال ،
فالجميع يستمع إلى
رأي سولوفيوف الذي تقوله هذه السيدة ، لكن سيكون من
الجيد أن يبدأ الخبراء في التعبير عن
آرائهم الحقيقية بدلاً من إطاعة
أوامر بوتين ، فما هو حقيقي يخمنه
أي شخص ، وهذا يعني بالنسبة للبعض
ضبط هذه السيدة.  تخبرنا أنها
لا تعرف شيئًا عن الدبابات عندما نسألها عن
رأيها ،
أعتقد أن هذه حرب سياسية
وليست حربًا للناس ، تخبر هذه السيدة
الفريق بما يفترض أن نفعله ،
وتقول إن آرائنا تعني القرفصاء
[موسيقى  ]
معزولون بشكل متزايد عن وجهات النظر الخارجية
وتحت تهديد الانتقام القاسي إذا كانوا
معارضين للروس عالقون في شبق
في حرب لا يريدونها مع زعيم
لا يمكنهم إزالته وخطر
التجنيد المحتمل قاب قوسين أو أدنى الذي
يفعلونه  ما فعله الروس
تاريخيًا في مواجهة
الشدائد بالتركيز على بقاءهم على قيد الحياة
نيك روبنسون سي إن إن لندن